By height and width,
this is the slimmest
building in the world.
What does it take from an
engineering perspective
to actually construct something like this?
It's a combination of very
advanced wind tunnel testing
that wasn't available a few years ago.
Okay.
Much stronger concrete
than was available a few years ago.
And a number of other engineering factors.
It really turned out to be
this amazing juxtaposition
of old and new.
As we stand here and you look up
you have this amazing
restored copper lantern
that we refabricated off original drawings
and then this amazing
contemporary tower behind it.
So it's that old and new play
that we were very excited
about as developers.
You don't get a chance
to do this very often.
I'm on the 43rd floor in a
$28.75 million apartment.
This is 50 feet of glass on Central Park.
The apartment is obviously quite nice
but the real star of the show is the view.
In the kitchen, when you're
taking a break from cooking
or watching someone cook for you
you can look out to Columbus
Circle, to New Jersey
all the way down Central Park to Harlem.
Each apartment takes up an entire floor
so when you step off the
elevator, you're home.
The front of the apartment
is entertaining spaces,
the back is bedrooms.
This apartment has three bedrooms,
so as you walk down a hallway
that's filled with more closet space
than most New Yorkers have as living space
you go into one of the three bedrooms
where there is a marble covered bathroom.
And then the bedroom itself.
You have views of the
Empire State Building.
You can actually see the terra cotta
on the side of the facade.
And of course you have views
through all of southern Manhattan.
I'm here in the master bathroom.
Next to me is a bathtub
that was custom designed
for this space.
The walls and floors and sinks,
even the insides of the sinks, are onyx.
The walls are more polished,
the floors are more
matte, if that matters.
And then over here is the shower.
And there is a window looking
straight out across Manhattan.
So even in the bathroom you've
got a view in this apartment.
I'm on the 82nd floor, above
all the residential spaces
standing in front of 800 tons of steel
that comprise the tuned mass damper
that basically counteracts
the sway of the building.
Now, even if this wasn't here,
the building would be fine.
It's exclusively for comfort.
And what it does is when the
building sways in one direction
it moves in the opposite direction
to keep the building as
straight and steady as possible.
Now, it's not just the steel,
it's also filled with sand.
So this is a colossal
contraption that takes up,
as you can see, the entire
floor of the building.
So we're on the exterior hoist,
I wouldn't want to say plummeting
but it certainly feels
like we're plummeting.
We're descending on the
exterior of the building.
It's definitely not for the faint of heart
or for anyone who has ever
confronted their own mortality
because there's a lot of jitters
and it's something that the
people who are building this
are quite inured to.
But for a casual visitor
it is, I would say,
absolutely terrifying.
We're standing in the 94 year old
historic Steinway Hall Atrium
which, as you can see,
is a pretty crazy place.
It's designed to give a
sense of place and grandeur
and ceremony to its original purpose
namely selling pianos.
And as a result, you see
intricately carved marble columns.
You see this plaster coffered ceiling.
You see this very large mural
that's in the process of being restored.
And you see it culminating
into this colossal crystal chandelier.
Which is hanging above the only thing
that doesn't quite make sense
namely the model of the 91
story 111 West 57th Street Tower
which is adjacent to
the Steinway building.